[Music]
Oh
you slap you lose you just favorite show
yes I'd say I do think that's it let's
see how last V dad fine actually
Thank You YouTube I don't always
complain the challenge is simple Scott
3000 I mean you're slow you lose that's
just the rule it's very simple bonus
point if you check out the merch look at
the description limited time only let's
go on with the video
everybody remember to not stop them it's
nothing fun this I err
let's begin I'm excited I can t really
one more thing in the ride itself yeah
if see I'm sorry after you that was a
real tough one wasn't it but I think we
made it through that one we didn't let
Scott no just just sleeping in a in a
junkyard no big deal everyone does this
I think this meme would work better if
it had the Russian anthem sigh I mean
Brad too will now edit that in
[Music]
your bunny brought your bunny brought
we're not but y'all see didn't that work
so much better
they just got that yet mmm I keep a
foodie shoving me at a clip Mirai Cleve
tagged over what it's a Emily I love
Russian school memes this because it
it's like what are they doing what is
this whole country doing no one knows
[Music]
seems like a fantastic place to get
educated i I really finally get wild all
the Eastern European people that watch
my channel and why they're such
intellectuals I finally understand if
you want to be an intellectual as well
you know you know we're how to get it I
feel like this has to be staged or
something but the fact that it isn't
just makes it so badass how can
something so written be so badass at the
same time like I don't understand trying
to grasp my head around this
yes I gotta see that again
I didn't Scout that it's not that that
taste yeah but what is wrong with your
country I don't understand what is right
what is wrong I don't understand which
is lost this program to bring you a
special report here's for the future
hair sorry to interrupt have I told you
about ass it's coming out on every
console ever in May check it out link in
the description
join the discord
[Music]
[Applause]
this is on ironically fire someone needs
to do an EDM dance mix of this please I
think the fact that it's so authentic
you know it that's what makes it funny
and I mean who said white people don't
have a culture there's plenty of it you
just kind of look to the east
[Music]
[Laughter]
no no oh
introducing Alexis love it's for
everyone for everyone works even better
it's for all of us it's our elects right
now oh it's always on nope it only hears
you when you use the wake word we chose
no no definitely hears you all the time
Alexa well what does it do
Alexa what do you do there's no pretty
good Kenya we go design it but don't you
like a people to bed Stan laughing OH
[Music]
we elect them what time is it Jesus
Christ you can access echo from anywhere
[Music]
need to get me one of those Suze pretty
good
[Music]
beautiful nothing like a Russian anthem
on a Finnish phone what do they think
what's going to happen you put your arm
inside a bear cage truly a country of
intellectuals I'm very proud
[Music]
okay alright moving on to the next video
that was Otis got there and I mine it
food skitter food day pushpa free
products purchased Nikko good stocker as
Ramiro's make business what's wrong with
your country I mean what's right with I
mean how else can you look this good
how else can you rock this look so hard
it's the only way all right
I lost okay I am I lost are you happy i
scrapped that what do you want from me
that's it for this week's you laugh you
slab I hope you guys enjoyed my fellow
comrades that's right I was looking for
a word that really shows that we're a
family they're more than just bros there
you go check out the marshal in your
description really appreciated a limited
time only support the channel
most likely since this will be
demonetised so I really appreciate it
guys thank you very much and they'd be
like if you lost and you liked it
watch your back pretty proud but it's it
so when I'm taking over you trying to
get like him bro flees to the base gonna
keep it with a pace and I'm never gonna
switch how's it going
get it like this when you wanna hit the
flo rida like I'm playing I promise I'll
never stop running pretty city and I'm
never gonna fly tell me when it go I'm
like whenever I'm done with this Pastor
Mike the Edgar